you know one of the things we love about
you and and Ashton so much is you guys
kind of are you see what you get what
you see is what you get and Ashton just
recently talked about his health Journey
oh yeah you know did that bring you guys
closer having to like you know sit and
talk about and those things bring you
closer as a family so this happened
right before covid so this was three
years ago
um I don't think that you have time to
sit and talk like you kind of just power
through you go you deal with it with
whatever health issue comes your way but
you still got kids you still got a
family you still got you gotta do you
gotta live life yeah and I think that
it's you know we are so fortunate to
have one another but as far as like
sitting there and and
incessantly talking about things no we
gotta you gotta act you gotta do you
gotta do well you guys did do the 90s
show and I'm geeked about it one week
you break up with me and the next week
you're Prince Charming I'm an incredibly
complex man Jackie
did it like freak your head a little bit
when you said okay I'm going back to do
this and now I'm married to this man
let me tell you first and foremost my
child without giving too much away in
this show is way too old to be my child
so I was like what what are we like teen
pair like so okay I was like whatever so
first of all my kids way too old I want
everybody to know not possible
um it is it's very good it's great in
fact and I think that anyone that's
never watched 70s that was a fan loved
it I think would be very very very very
happy with how they the inciting
incident of this of the whole series
cool yeah good deal but my kid in it is
that's a soap opera move you know in
soap operas they have like the kid and
they're two and they come back like six
months later and the kid's grown and the
parents are still the same so well this
kicks you all to be
my very clear I don't know what's me
and we'll put I invented
classmate has made claims against you
don't talk about what happened that
night Are you seriously trying to
threaten me right now I hadn't read the
book this movie miva
OMG
so good it sat with me in so many
different ways how difficult was it
though for you to get into the mindset
of what Tiffany Ani went through and you
know kind of bring yourself into those
moments I mean I don't know if I'm gonna
sound like a sociopath but it wasn't
that hard I don't
know when it comes to acting like I
don't I don't live and breathe it when I
don't come home I have a I've always
said this who I am and what I do are two
very different things uh understanding
the why of the characters always the
easiest way in and I you know I guess
reverse engineered it so I'm like how
did she end up here right these are the
incidents that happened can't control
those incidents you can't fault yourself
for those incidents you have to forgive
yourself for those incidents that is the
film so for me to do it I think I had to
approach in the very I guess oddly
logical way yeah yeah and then allow the
emotions to then take over how lucky for
you though being on this set and having
Jessica have written the book and also
write the film did you just really get
to sit and talk and like go over stuff
with her or do you work like that she
was really great about like I'm here if
you need me but this isn't an
autobiography okay like she was really
great and that's what makes her thinking
a magical writer is that she can create
these characters live with them base
them partially on herself and then let
you have the character right and I think
so often writers sometimes aren't ready
to let go of their character and
directors as well which is what I also
think makes Mike Barker so incredible is
that oftentimes directors take ownership
of the story and ownership of these
characters to a certain extent where
they don't even allow the actors to have
an interpretation of them and the two of
them together was like this incredible
peanut butter and jelly sandwich of like
creativity they're fun together too
she's talking to them they're a lot of
fun we spent a lot of time together
um I I assume you've seen the film
many attacks so when I was watching it I
think for me too it was
um not so much trauma but I did feel
like my teenage self like I was watching
my teenage self and having those
experiences all over again
um I don't know if you felt that way in
some ways we did but I was thinking too
like what could I tell young Michelle
about you know how to do something
different do you think about that and
what would you tell young Mila I don't
know what I would tell but I think I
thought about this and I think that
that's what's the beautiful thing about
this film is hope that you walk out and
have a lot of conversations like this
I'm so grateful I was like I wonder what
in my life prevented me from getting
myself into this system like so you know
and I can I can go and and without
putting blame on on me without putting
blame on Tiffany she didn't do anything
but somehow she got to this situation
how right we you and I both could have
been in the same exact situation in
multiple times in their lives I imagine
how did I not get there right God
blessed that we did not get there yeah
and you have Kiara who was fantastic
um I know they told me that you really
kind of mothered her a lot and you
mentioned her I mean I mean I'd like to
say more like sister and her but okay
mentored her let's let's say that she
she's so brilliant she doesn't she's
gonna be fine without me okay like let's
give Kara credit where credit is due
she's an incredible actor she's so
professional she's so fun she's so smart
she's she's great she doesn't need me
but I'm here should she okay like if
there's anything she needs I am right
here there's so many heavy moments and
heavy topics I mean the school shooting
was very in your face I thought the the
sexual assault How It Was Written was
really interesting because it was a
little murky and she's not sure how she
feels and then she is sure but she's not
sure and it it that actually is what
really sat with me because I thought
well this is a conversation piece for so
many yeah people at home yep I think we
have to remember it's a very good
question for Jess and I'll tell you
um Jess wrote Jessica who Jessica who
wrote the the film wrote the book also
wrote an op-ed piece about when this
happened to her and so this is her
interpretation of her version or her
truth how she experienced it and that is
how it felt for her and that is how it
how she recalls it as far as the school
shooting I think that's just the
unfortunate you know unraveling of the
story and that's kind of you know for
for her in the book it was a very
interesting jumping off point of just
finding reasonings and and ownership of
what you did how you did what you could
have done different guilt there's a
million things and I think it just you
know helps service the story so your
mama do when you when you tackle
material like this does it ever make you
think like okay
what kind of conversations can I now
have with my son and my daughter
and uh okay so there's still little yes
they are
not yet not about this I know and
there's probably some parents are like
you need to start I'm more inclined I'd
rather talk to them now about
um
you know the birds and the bees so to
speak and anything else uh I'm not ready
to talk about
um school shootings I can't do it I you
know they do drills in school so when I
grow up you did earthquake drills
absolutely and now they do
they don't call them active shooter
drills for little kids but they have
different names for them right and they
do them that gave me goosebumps it's sad
because they're worse just to think that
this is the society that we are living
like that's the one my six and eight
year old go to school doing an
earthquake drill and also a call it
whatever you shall but an active shooter
drill at six and eight we don't talk
about it
[Music]